and in the field of physics dr. Amy
Farrah Fowler and dr. Sheldon Cooper
for their discovery of super asymmetry
just to be clear this isn't a date yeah
I know why are you holding my view thank
you your Majesties thank you to the
Nobel Committee we are deeply honored I
would just like to take this moment to
say to all the young girls out there who
dream about science as a profession go
for it
it is the greatest job in the world and
if anybody tells you you can't don't
listen and now speaking of not listening
my husband dr. Sheldon Cooper Sheldon
well did you finish it great job thank
you dr. Fowler I have a very long and
somewhat self-centered speech here but
I'd like to set it aside
because this honor doesn't just belong
to me I wouldn't be up here if it
weren't for some very important people
in my life beginning with my mother and
father meemaw brother and sister and my
other family who I'm so happy to have
here with us is that Buffy the Vampire
Slayer I was under a misapprehension
that my accomplishments were mine alone
nothing could be further from the truth
I have been encouraged sustained
inspired and tolerated not only by my
wife but by the greatest group of
friends anyone ever had I'd like to ask
them to stand dr. Rajesh Koothrappali
dr. Bernadette Rostenkowski Wolowitz
astronaut Howard Wolowitz and my two
dearest friends in the world
penny Hofstadter
and dr. Leonard Hofstadter I was there
the moment Leonard and Penny met he said
to me that their babies would be smart
and beautiful and now that they're
expecting I have no doubt that that will
be the case in Sheldon a I haven't told
my parents yet but oh sorry
don't tell anyone that last thing that's
a secret Howard Bernadette Raj penny
Leonard I apologize if I haven't been
the friend you deserve but I want you to
know in my way I love you all and I love
you thank you